good afternoon again everybody my name
is Aziz an Aziz and I hope everybody had
a great lunch and we're gonna have a
great session coming up I am a faculty
at the Center for building performance
and diagnostic which is part of the
School of Architecture and we've been
working with this cut Institute and
investigating researching and developing
technologies for energy reduction and in
demand-side management and what we're
looking at right now is commercializing
some of those technologies so it can be
available in the marketplace we do have
a set of outstanding panelists today to
debate and give us insight on the topic
of driving the built environment to
higher performance with energy-efficient
technologies and innovation our
panelists include Scott renautas
who's associate vice chancellor for
facilities at the University of
Pittsburgh thank you for coming
Michael Barnard the project project
director at Oxford development katie
Flynn Energy Manager at Giant Eagle
Aurora Sherrod executive director of
Green Building Alliance and David came
vice chancellor for infrastructure and
sustainability and the chief facilities
officer at the University of colder
about ball Arado I like the title CFO as
being chief our facilities officer
that's fantastic so our panelists came
with very impressive resumes and I would
suggest that you read them in your
agendas or online also we have Steve
Gunter which is our director of
facilities and operations and I'm gonna
give the mic to him he'll be moderating
this session thank you very much
you guys done and it's great to be here
with this panel I'm most excited about
these chairs and being the first group
to sit in them we were just at the my
Nana's house for Easter over the weekend
and I can tell you if these chairs were
in her living room we would not be
sitting in them we'd be looking at them
they're that beautiful so we're gonna
kick this off with a quote that sounds
like it's exactly suited for this
conference
it starts with working together we're
going to help bill help businesses
cities and states achieve their climate
goals and accelerate the transition to a
low-carbon future sounds like something
that the folks sitting in the audience
on stage here are already helping to do
that quotes actually from the University
of California system president Janet
Napolitano during a launch of the
University Climate Change coalition
better known now as you see three that
happened in February 2018 and that
coalition plans to pull together best
practices policies and recommendations
from all the UC three forums across the
country into a framework that can be
replicated around the world
so David first question goes to you your
Chancellor is one of 13 North American
leading universities that has joined the
push for research driven climate
policies and solutions focusing first
not just on your campus but your broader
community tell us a little bit more
about you c3 how it's gonna drive higher
performance at your campus the
University of Colorado at Boulder
throughout history the university has
been a respected pillar in the community
across the globe our institutions are
driven by two fundamental activities
research and education we strive to
shape and educate the next generation of
citizens and leaders we're also about
discovery finding the truth sharing
knowledge and solving problems it's in
our DNA this is what we do every day day
in and day out about a month ago as
Steve mentioned cu-boulder along with 12
other North American universities from
the U
Canada and Mexico announced the
formation of the University climate
change coalition which is rooted in the
idea that research universities should
take on an expanded role in creating a
better understanding of climate change
through research data collection and
modeling that can inform action pull
particularly at the local and regional
level in a non-political way right it's
about facts so so what do we bring to
the table expertise in areas including
climate modeling energy storage
next-generation renewables smart energy
and efficient technology sustainable
transportation innovations as well as
deep understanding of the social
sciences economics policy and regulation
and it's not just us you know we have
partners across the country and across
the world
who can also do these things a real
example of what we're doing at
cu-boulder is a creation of a living
sustainability laboratory on our campus
where we plan to integrate research in
education into our daily operations to
create a fertile ground for innovation
entrepreneurship by bringing together
students faculty industry partners the
community venture capital with the goal
of taking Applied Research quickly into
commercialization so that we can
actually make a difference I'm
particularly excited about the
opportunity to enhance our operations as
well I'm also in charge of the
facilities through robust data analytics
machine learning the Internet of Things
artificial intelligence I think that
could be a game-changer in how we
actually operate our facilities more
efficiently as well as opportunities for
cost savings from an infrastructure
standpoint sustainability is intertwined
with everything we do from how we
operate retrofit and construct buildings
to how we plan for the future of the
campus it's not just about the
initiatives themselves but it's about
saving money using our resources more
efficiently
I have a saying the most efficient
building is the one that we don't build
enhancing resiliency and leading by
example in the community it's about how
we integrate the built environment into
the natural environment we're also
focused on how
we can more closely integrate
sustainability education research and
operations into a seamless and well
coordinated efforts
that's enduring collaborative and most
important impactful this means we must
make improvements on how we use our
facilities reducing energy and water
consumption integrating smart energy and
renewable technologies promoting
sustainability and procurement how many
folks actually buy stuff from Amazon in
all the packaging well I went to a
conference and I actually sat down with
Amazon and said it can we do something
together to reduce that and as we do
this and we think about the investments
that we need to make in resources time
and effort it really is a balancing act
between what we need with what we want
with what we need to change and what we
can afford to fund in every case it has
to make business sense it has to pencil
out or it's not going to be sustainable
that's the challenge but the technology
exists the ideas are there the question
is how do we work together to move this
agenda forward another key area that
we're really focusing on is climate
resiliency and more broadly community
resiliency so this impacts everybody in
this room in one way or another this is
what keeps me up at night how do I make
sure that the doors are open at the
University this is what kept me up that
night when I worked at the White House
in my past life it was about the
continuity of the presidency and our
form of government now it's about
education and research for others in
this room and maybe about keeping the
production line going or maybe just you
know making sure that you have power so
that you have heat at night in the
winter you know we live in dynamics and
sometimes unforgiving environment so if
the lessons from hurricanes Katrina
sandy Harvey Maria don't wake us up what
we'll so we need to be prepared for
these disruptions we need to invest in
capabilities to help weather these
storms we need to work as a community to
identify and mitigate vulnerabilities
where at a minimum we need to be able to
keep our folks safe
be able to respond quickly and resume
normal operations as I said before
sustainability also means that our
solutions are cost-effective if this has
been a focus for our team at CU it's not
just about doing it and it also has to
make sense we're focusing on becoming
smarter and more sustainable so that we
can become more resilient well we can't
do this in a vacuum we need to establish
nurture and expand research innovation
partnerships collaboration and to really
make an impact it has to be a
partnership between everybody that's in
this room and more importantly everyone
that's not in this room Thanks right
thank you David and just as a reminder
to the audience that David's comments
covered such a broad range we are going
to leave time at the end for questions
from the audience please use the app you
have information on your table about how
to access it and won't be able to
address those questions at the end so
moving from a North American focus to a
US initiative in a turn to Aurora
talk about 401 million square feet of
space that's united to try to catalyze
transformation in their built
environment I'm talking about the 2030
districts nationwide
we've got about one-fifth of that
overall portfolio here in Pittsburgh it
started about five years ago downtown as
it expanded include our neighborhood
here in the Auckland District within
Pittsburgh David talked about a number
of things that are going to happen
through the uc3 initiative and some of
those may have parallels to things that
have already started here in Pittsburgh
with the 2030 district what have been
some of the achievements for folks that
may not be familiar in the audience with
2030 and how you achieve that success
the portfolio that's included is so
diverse how do you drive success across
that diverse portfolio against such an
ambitious call see if I could not hit
all of those things so taking a step
back a little bit for context for those
of you in the audience who aren't
familiar with it in the early 2000s
there was an architect named ed nazriya
out of New Mexico who did some back of
the envelope calculation said we're
gonna solve this whole climate change
thing
what's building's contribution
ran the numbers and said wow that is
significant our existing building stock
is consuming a ton we're continuing to
build and renovate new buildings over
time what needs to happen if we're going
to move buildings from being one of the
major contributors for climate change to
part of the solution is these 2030 goals
and the answer essentially in numbers
which I know a lot of you love and I do
too is carbon neutral for all new
construction by the year 2030 and 50%
reductions in energy use for existing
buildings below baselines by the year
2030 then you have to layer in 50%
reductions below baselines of water use
and transportation emissions and oh yeah
everybody needs to do it so when he does
in the early 2000s it went out to the
architecture urban planning community
and they said this is great and they
started working with some really
forward-thinking owners and institutions
across the country and just ticking away
one building at a time until an
individual named Brian Geller out of
Seattle I was walking around Seattle saw
their district steam plant and said huh
what if I talked to all the owners who
are connected to that facility and asked
them with their existing buildings to
contribute to these 2030 challenge pools
what would that do and he created the
first 2030 district the Seattle 2030
district in collaboration with the city
of Seattle in Pittsburgh we thought that
was such a great idea that we adopted
the model in 2012 we launched in August
2012 with 61 buildings in just over 30
million square feet so remember those
numbers and just in downtown we did it
quietly we talked to owners and
institutions who we thought would be
interested and it's a really interesting
conversation to go to a building owner
and say 50% reductions by 2030 energy
water transportation emissions and oh
yeah we're a green building organization
so we're gonna help you improve indoor
air quality as well because you can't
just seal up a building tight and a lot
of people were really interested
especially those who always thought that
they didn't have a seat at the green
building table because they weren't
eligible for a certification they
weren't moving fast enough they weren't
doing a major retro
fit or their performance was just not
very good so we created a safe space for
people to do this across sectors so
commercial office buildings cultural
institutions public buildings k-12
schools retail establishments and we
started making it voluntary safe
baseline benchmarks the you know it's
over time and there's a geographic
boundary and all of those things really
resonated with Pittsburghers so Steve
said 401 million square feet
internationally so there are 19 20 30
districts in North America Pittsburgh
has somewhere between 20 and 25% of all
the square footage committed to those
2030 challenge goals right here so we're
somewhere around 500 buildings and 80
million square feet if you want to know
the most up-to-date numbers you're gonna
have to wait two weeks until we unveil
our 2017 performance numbers on April
19th but it's really worked amazingly
well and Pittsburgh has just embraced
the approach the time period and they
really like that
it's performance-based it's not
prescriptive right so you're gonna hear
from a number of owners up here on the
stage today who have been doing these
things for a long time but as a small
nonprofit organization I can't go to any
one of them and say great here's your
list 1 2 3 do it in this order that that
doesn't work the way that buildings work
capital I just aren't that way operating
budgets aren't that way you have to let
people do it on their own time in their
own space in their own way when it's
right for them and then you give them
that network where they can learn from
each other and then because it's in
Pittsburgh we have a downtown boundary
and an Oakland boundary as we've
expanded the number of people that are
talking to each other has really
increased and they really enjoy that but
hearing it from each other is so much
more powerful than if I said it or you
can't light says it or a service
provider says it it's just like very
different when Pitt and John Eagles sit
down and are talking to each other I'm
like oh is this what you're doing for
your coolers I could do that in my
dining establishments and it's kind of
amazing the takeaways that you see from
those types of interactions I think I
had everything I think you did it's
great
another key to success here in
Pittsburgh I don't think the district
boundaries cross a bridge or a tunnel
and so me not yet
yeah and no spoiler alert about the
results coming out in two weeks all
right fantastic
well Scott your campus is signed up for
the 2030 district and there's been a
number of other really exciting things
happening at the University of
Pittsburgh let's start out with some
background going back 15 years ago on
your campus in 2003 you your camp has
established the mascara Center for
Sustainable innovation that's your home
for education and research related to
sustainability five years after that
your faculty got involved and the Senate
passed a statement on sustainability in
conjunction with issuing the first
greenhouse gas inventory or your large
and expansive campus covering all facets
of your operations we advanced another
five years beyond that to the next
milestone your campus published its
report on sustainability which for the
first time ever put in print all of the
achievements related to sustainability
across your campus life talking about
research talking about housing talking
about student talking about justice just
as well as you're talking about energy
to add to all of that this last December
your Chancellor issued from his desk the
Pitt sustainably sustainability plan
which describes itself as quote a
strategic framework that calls for
dramatic improvement in sustainability
across our university by 2030 know no
coincidence on date but also when I got
that milestone out there the thing that
resonated with me most are those words
dramatic improvement stated from the
Chancellor's desk in the opening letter
in the report you've already done so
much on your campus obviously that's a
call to do so much more can you tell us
a little bit about the plan specifically
about the things that you're going to be
doing to help to achieve the
Chancellor's goals great thank you very
much Stephen so it was a new plan it's
the first comprehensive sustainability
plan for the University of Pittsburgh
I worked with the university-wide
sustainability committee formed in fall
of 2016
just a year later last this last fall we
took the plan to the Chancellor and to
your point he said it's not dramatic
enough it's not bold enough I said well
I think it is he said now I think you
need to
and so we've fully embraced in print the
2030 district goals and he said I want
to see a 50% reduction in greenhouse gas
emissions I want to see 50% reduction or
a 50% of your electrical power supplied
by renewable energy I want to see it's
50 cubed and make sure I get them all
here they're relatively new
I left the press and at least 50% below
the national average or energy use
intensities now we got a little bit of
homework that we're still working on and
what does that last one mean the other
works are pretty clear in either way
those 50 percents in the fourth one that
I didn't mention that I'm not going to
talk about is water intensity but all of
those are significant changes for a very
diverse you know 12 and 1/2 million
square-foot university with buildings
dating back you know about a hundred
years to brand-new modern buildings
which are less challenging but right off
the bat what we and we heard that a
little bit in David's talk what we
realize is one is these aspirational
goals are going to cost they're gonna
benefit but they're also going to cost
and so we feel it's incumbent upon us to
figure out you know what that what that
advantage is and is it worth the cost
for the university now we've committed
to those aspirational goals since the
Chancellor signed that and it's right
there up front in page 1 since he'd
signed those ambitious goals we've been
meeting every other week in facilities
management on that energy piece on those
450s and what we've what we found is you
know despite having signed up for the
2030 we never really had a comprehensive
implementation plan roadmap on how we're
gonna get there
so that's what we've been doing you know
every other week since then we've
implemented a what we call project
payback fund so the university has
committed five million dollars for
energy projects that will pay back in
five to seven years and we haven't
nailed down what that time frame is
obviously is we're new to this newly
implementing this we feel there's a lot
of low-hanging fruit and hopefully we'll
be able to come up with some rapid
payback quickly so what are we doing
what are some of those energy projects
were looking at to use that part of a
project payback funds we're looking at
continuous Commission fact just this
morning before I came here I was in the
meeting looking at another approach at
continuous commissioning which would
look promising
we're looking at doing energy audits
we've conducted the initial energy audit
16 of our buildings out of our 130
some buildings did an initial 16 what we
called our energy Hobbs and David will
remember that term from the Navy but
those are our most wasteful buildings
looking at an EU eye perspective and so
we've got those ECMs we're gonna lump
those in along with some approach for
continuous commissioning and we are also
going to do campus-wide lighting survey
we're gonna look at tying that because
this you know we got to show payback so
that lighting survey will include some
select replacement so I social energy
savings and we didn't want this energy
project payback fund to be tied to just
doing studies you know we wanted it to
literally each piece of that payback and
then one of the big things that we're
doing is trying to figure out what are
our target EU is across the campus as I
mentioned we got some buildings that are
about a hundred years old some buildings
that are much newer so are as you can
imagine our energy use intensity is it's
all over the map and we're trying to
find those targets that are reasonable
and worth the investment in those older
buildings and then seeing what we can
also do even in the newer buildings to
tighten that up and so we are in the
process right now of trying to define
with our design partners what a status
quo a better and a best might cost and
what those target EU eyes would look
like and so then you would as we go
through the design process we would say
hey you know we want you to in the
schematic design in the concept phase
give us some preliminary numbers for
what is a status quo a better and a
Bassel so we're pretty excited about
that we're in the infancy stages a lot
of us we're in the infancy stages but
again that that sustainability plan has
has kicked us all in the behind to get
going
and so similar to Dave and I were
comparing notes similar to the
University of Colorado
you know we're revamping our design
standards to make all of our buildings
perform better and I think that's great
it's amazing how a commitment from the
top can create alignment and break down
silos within a university and bring the
whole campus together against a unified
goal and and the planning is incredibly
important implementation is what
delivers on the outcome that people are
promising under the 2030s okay let's
switch to you and talk a little bit
about implementation the drive in the
built environment it's not just about
large institutions campuses it gets down
to individual in your case individual
stores and making them perform that can
not only be a good thing for the
environment but it can be great for
making your business competitive and
changing the guest experience so the
question remains though how do we drive
those buildings if we look at the goals
overall on where we need to get to as
the country buildings consume 30 percent
of electricity or 30 percent overall the
energy they're not moving as fast as
they should in terms of their share of
the overall energy marketplace
sometimes that gap has to do not just
with the planning but with the
implementation of it you've got about
400 retail locations across four states
that's a huge portfolio and not all
connected and nestled within a closed
geographic proximity how do you drive
implementation and success across like
giant Eagles thank you and it is really
challenging when you have so many
different locations and you know how to
save energy it's just going and how do
you actually flip those switches change
out the equipment and actually make that
improvements really challenging so we're
really fortunate in Giant Eagle we have
that top-down commitment already Laura
cret our CEO sees sustainability is
really a strategic priority and she sets
the expectation that we're going to be
continuously improving our energy
so that makes it very easy a Giant Eagle
to explain why we need to do that as a
result of that top-down commitment we
have this wonderful cross-functional
team and giant eagle and I think this is
really key to implementing projects so
on an ongoing basis people that work in
sustainability engineering procurement
energy procurement and operations meet
on a continuous basis to evaluate
different projects and what we do is
then prioritize projects based on what
technology can we roll out to all the
stores what technology applies to our
most energy-intensive stores and how
easy is it to implement it what's the
payback associated with it because we
really want to implement the projects
that are going to touch the most
locations most dramatically first to
generate the most savings and then we
can take that savings and use it to
justify additional projects as well so
really that cross-functional team is
really key in implementing projects one
tool that we use to gain acceptance
around projects is we always pilot a
technology I can pretty much guarantee
you that we'll never blindly roll out a
project all of our locations without
really rigorously testing it I love
doing pilots because it's a way of
engaging people that aren't really
familiar with energy and sustainability
to show the value of a project one of my
favorite days that I've ever spent
working at Giant Eagle was the day that
we were doing an LED pilot on our sales
floor and what we did is we went into
one store and we retrofitted half of the
sales floor with LEDs and the other half
we left as fluorescents we then invited
all the executives to literally walk the
store so they could literally see priam
prost post project what we were trying
to do and at the same time I showed them
we have real time energy monitoring on
all of our stores so I used that as a
really valuable tool for telling the
energy story and I was literally able
show them exactly how much energy we
reduced they could see aesthetically
this won't help hurt the stores it's
gonna really improve our guest
experience and oh by the way this is
we're actually saving that much energy
they could physically see it so I think
that's really important when you pilot
projects it also gives you the
opportunity for feedback which is very
important so literally that day
executives were going up to guests and
asking what do you think about these
lights do you like it you know what I
mean so it was really aid it was really
nice because we were able to get that
feedback and go to team members that are
gonna be in the stores every single day
and ask how they feel about it so a lot
of times that's really helpful because I
mean you're when you're in that
highlighting stage you can refine the
rollout before you you know roll out
something to all the stores then realize
oh shoot I wish I had made these three
changes before doing so one thing that's
really important when you're talking
about implementing projects is to talk
about all of the benefits associated
with the project so it's not just energy
you have that aesthetic value you might
have maintenance savings so it's really
important that when you have that
cross-functional team it enables you to
look at a project very holistically and
talk about all the benefits associated
with it one thing that's also really key
into implementing rollouts is to kind of
minimize how many rollouts you have to
do so when you're doing something like a
lighting project you want to see are
there any kind of peripheral projects
that I want to pull into this rollout so
a really great example is where towards
the end of implementing LED across all
of our sales floor when we were at the
beginning of that projects we looked at
the lighting controls and we actually
realized we want to pair a dimming
system with this LED retrofit because we
can maximize the savings of the project
we're reducing upfront costs because now
we have one rollout instead of two
rollouts so that's something that's
really important you're implementing a
project you want to make sure what other
projects do I want to wrap in to this
roll up one thing that I don't think
people talk about enough but I worry
about it all the time having 400
locations is how can we simplify energy
projects and
terms of implementation so I don't know
hopefully people are familiar with giant
Eagle but here in the city if you think
about all of our stores they're vastly
different from one another if you want
an example go to the Giant Eagle in
Squirrel Hill and then go to our
shooting site Market District location
incredibly different stores so when we
do something like an led rollout I don't
have the time and internal resources to
necessarily do a custom solution at
every single store so how can I actually
roll this out in a time effective manner
I can't be upgrading our stores for the
next five years I need to get it done
within a year so this ties into the
dimming systems that we paired with our
LED retrofit rather than pick let's say
hundreds of different fixtures that we
would need to actually implement this
rollout we were able to narrow it down
to ten but but then because we have the
dimming control system we can then
custom the light levels at every single
store so it makes it very easy to do the
rollout and meet the needs of every
single store without having to go to
every single store do a lighting layout
to a light analysis and things like that
so it helps really ease the
implementation one thing you also have
to work with is all of your partners
when you're getting ready to do an
implementation project you have to
really be able to trust your vendors you
want to partner with your utilities if
you're pursuing things like rebates make
sure you're really getting all the value
you can and also set expectations set
expectations for your vendor in terms of
timeline in terms of what you actually
want the outcome to be so everyone is on
the same page and then when you actually
start to implement the project make sure
you're in constant communication make
sure you're actually following your
timeline
make sure you're sharing lessons learned
if you have one crew that they found an
efficiency and they're able to you know
reduce install time by 10% you want to
make sure that all the install teams are
sharing from that knowledge and you're
benefiting from it so once you're
underway with your role you want to be
in constant communication make sure
you're actually implementing your
as necessary and one important aspect of
implementing project that I think a lot
of times people forget about is when
it's done following up reporting on it
you know one thing that I always kind of
laugh about it is when it comes to
energy fit and see a lot of people are
focused on the P&L statements and I
always track energy cost energy
consumption and energy price so as we're
doing this LED retrofit I'm all over the
stores watching their films watching
their energy line and there was a
handful of stores that I noticed their
energy costs went up after this LED
project so I start stressing out I go
into all the bills and I realize okay
they actually reduce consumption to line
items increased to the point it
completely negated from a cost
perspective or LED rollouts and then I
actually had to create the story
internally and say listen this turned
from a cost savings to a cost avoidance
and actually show people we absolutely
reduced and the project was successful
and this is what would have happened if
we hadn't done it so it's really
important that you're communicating with
your vendors communicating internally on
the success of a project you also want
to monitor it to make sure you actually
did receive that savings for a lot of
projects you can install controls
incorrectly and then they're actually
not functional so you always want to do
that due diligence after you implement a
project communicate that success and
sure it's working as it should be and
that eases kind of when you have your
next project because you already have
that internal buy-in which is so
critical in to getting more projects
done thanks Katie I think it's amazing
how Giant Eagle has such a commitment to
brand standards that that adds actually
complexity and trying to implement
projects because you've customized your
brand to all the different real estate
that you occupy and and you've done it
in a way that has not diminished
best experience when you've rolled out a
project across rural water I've been
with Giant Eagle for about three years
and when I started at Giant Eagle I was
like we have to have kind of like groups
of stores and it took me about a year to
really accept that everyone one of our
community is that we're in is different
and every one of our stores in those
communities really see I only thought
that existed on a college campus you
guys can write everything every building
is unique it happens at Giant Eagle to
talk about unique buildings Michael I'll
turn to you for last panel question
build smart build sustainable operate
efficiently those are words that
resonate with this audience but it's
also ripped directly from your from
corporate material from Oxford
Development but sometimes the markets
don't reward cost or complexity
complexity associated with the type of
innovations that we'd all like to push
so you're a private developer tell me
what limitations you face when you're
implementing new methodologies or
technology what approach does Oxford use
to drive improvements in buildings
performance while still facing that
challenge well I think in general for us
the biggest challenge is like any other
project construction projects they're
very difficult to start and they're
difficult to start because of budget
because of schedule and so whenever
we're trying to implement new
methodologies technologies you know
construction practices may be a little
counterintuitive to the design and
construction process to say well how do
we reevaluate what we did the last time
and that's going to stretch the schedule
potentially scratch it the stretches the
budget it provides uncertainty which
tends to be the the enemy of the
investors the lenders and the folks that
are actually writing the checks so what
we've done at least is tried to look at
it more of an incremental approach you
know how can we take the next project to
a little higher standard we're very
fortunate we have leadership in our
company who has stepped up and you know
is looking at it from what's the right
thing to do
for people for the planet for you know
the whether it be 2030 district lead
certification the p4 measures here
Pittsburgh those are all things that are
very important to us and when it comes
from the top down we look for ways to
take the next step in that direction but
again I think the biggest challenges for
us are proving proving it out in an
efficient process and then also being
able to execute the prop the projects
efficiently so that they're successful
in the end
and then obviously lead to the next
project so we aren't certainly aren't
doing as much as we'd like I know from
when we look at it internally but we
threw that incremental approach it's
we've been very successful in elevating
and going beyond what the minimum we
have to do and hopefully starting to
achieve more of those aspirational
standards and and we're more fortunate
here locally to have resources that can
assist us with that and can also kind of
set expectations from a market
standpoint that are above that of kind
of the cheapest ability you can build by
code so we leverage those relationships
and hopefully are proving to be you know
one of the leaders in act in that arena
that way fantastic it not being able to
do everything we'd like I think is a
common theme across the folks here up on
stage as well as in the audience we've
got about five minutes left so I think I
have time for one question that's come
in from the audience and I'm just going
to toss that to the panel at large
please any of you jump in on this the
question is does making building energy
buildings energy efficient lead to a
rise in either the construction or other
operating costs and if they do how do
you motivate your administration or
prospective owners into taking on those
higher costs anybody Steven I'll jump on
that first I yes
and particularly on the operational side
I learned that as I mentioned we have a
wide range of portfolios that's the
older buildings as Aurora said you know
they didn't have to take in the same air
changes that we have to take in now and
so when we remodel those we put
high-efficiency systems in but guess
what I'm taking out window air
conditioners and it's or radiator units
I'm replacing window air conditioners
I'm adding air conditioner window air
conditioning when there wasn't and so my
operating cost go up and I learned I
learned you got to be very careful on
how to questions on how you present that
data and I got wrapped around the axle
the first time I tried to explain it
just the 5x to the board and so I've
learned my lesson and it's you have to
be careful you have to tell the story on
how how that energy cost is his better
it might be more for that space than it
was but we've bought a benefit so it
becomes a cost avoidance rather than a
cost savings I think it's yes and no and
so you know the example of the LED
lights is a great example right so make
cost more upfront look at the lifecycle
cost may be significantly more
especially have to pay you know 80 to 80
dollars an hour for electrician to come
out and real amp you know every two or
three years versus every 15 years right
so I think you know what Scott talked
about what we're working on as well
changing the design criteria so that we
actually are more thoughtful and what we
put in there
and then I think more importantly going
from what you talked about the first
cost of construction to lifecycle costs
and so looking at the entire system from
you know when you build it when you plan
it and build it to disposal
looking at the life cycle of the people
and seeing what's the right investment
to them to make and doing that in the
early stages of planning I think is the
direction that we need to head in and so
the focus has always been on the first
cost how can I save money on this you
know multi-million dollar project well
you may be saving $500,000 but you're
gonna be paid eight million dollars over
sixty years of the life of the building
which is probably not the smartest
investment so I think that approach is
different so we answer this question
every day
up-down in sideways and we make the case
for it with all sorts of different
owners and sizes and types and the
answer is it doesn't have to but
sometimes it does and sometimes people
get super excited about everything that
they're doing and they want to change
the paradigm and that's a really
important thing that I think David just
hit on is you know this question about
buildings consume 40 percent of all the
energy that we use in the United States
we've been using that statistic in the
green building industry for 25 years and
the number hasn't changed that's the
problem right because we're not shifting
we're just like doing these incremental
reductions and this is why things like
the Passivhaus movement has really
resonated with some people because it
takes an entirely different approach
it's like great take energy use cut it
down by half at the beginning a minimum
could have got my half maybe all the way
down to 10% and then have your most
efficient building layer on renewables
and don't worry about it because you're
building an asset and I think that's one
of the things that we sometimes forget
about in the building industry it's not
just about economics we're building
somewhere that's gonna be a place it's
going to contribute to that community
and our environment for 50 100 200 years
and we really need to be treating our
buildings like assets
lifecycle assessment also talking about
risk as well so talking about what
happens if energy prices double in ten
years we're planning on this building
being here for another twenty years so
you know both in terms of energy costs
in terms of sustainability in terms of
resilience we also have to be talking
about risk especially when it comes to
new construction and we're gonna be
stuck with that asset for decades to
come
this is really the best opportunity to
avoid some of that risk so we're not
implementing projects halfway through
and then this benefit from doing it from
the beginning well I agree with ya I
agree with everything that's been said I
think that the challenge again is also
there certainly as that first cost and
it is a challenge but the and the
lifecycle cost is something that needs
to be evaluated and that's something
that at least in a lot of the markets
that we deal with changing that paradigm
because so much of our lifecycle costs
are reliant on tenant behaviors and you
know where this where the savings are
actually realized and how that affects
kind of the success of the project on
the economic model and it's something
that we're working to try to get better
at it's a little different than an
institutional scenario where you know
the same people that own it live there
and you know can be controlled maybe a
little bit better one of the biggest
differentiators for us is the would be
in some of the amenities and the the
attractiveness of the property so some
of the low-hanging fruit whether it's
you know
enhanced energy performance that the
tenants realize on you know where we can
do it incrementally evey stations that
are put in our properties things like
that that they see and we start to see
the tenants that want it pay maybe a
slight premium for it that's where it
helps to feed the model back and it's
easier to take those things on at the
beginning thank you I think we're at the
conclusion of time so I want to thank
the panel for the things that you did
before today at your respective
institutions or organizations than the
leadership that you exhibit to help
drive this important aspect of the built
environment into higher performance
thanks for your insights for the
audience today looking forward to
interacting with you more throughout the
rest of the conference
[Applause]